bonjour à toutes et à tous alors je suis
désolé mais c'est quoi ce bordel disney
semble clairement faire évoluer son
business plan au vu des conditions
sanitaires
on est vraiment dans une période inédite
dans tous les cas on savait qu'ils
souhaitaient investir dans le petit
écran
on est content donc voilà bref on n'a
pas trop de temps à perdre parce que là
franchement il ya plein de séries à
traiter je pensais vous faire une vidéo
sur star wars et marvel compilé mais au
final il ya trop de série a annoncé donc
voila j'aimerais néanmoins vous dire que
vous êtes beaucoup à regarder la chaîne
mais à ne pas être abonné c'est
clairement le moment rien à voir plein
de choses à dire là surtout avec 2021 et
toutes les séries
voilà la chaîne va être riche en contenu
l'a vu toutes les annonces
bref les deux groupes commençons par
star wars et on en parlait dans ma
dernière vidéo sur l'univers mandat
lauriane est un grand succès pour la
firme et surtout précurseur à de
nouvelles productions
on ne va pas se mentir que star wars
semble prendre une direction semblable à
marvel mais je pense que cela va
clairement faire du bien à la saga c'est
donc deux nouvelles séries qui ont été
annoncées se déroulant dans la période
de l'histoire du mandaloriens la
première se nomme star wars
rodgers of the republic nous n'avons
aucune information la concernant pour le
moment mais étant dans l'air du mandat
lauriane il est très facile de
soupçonner que la série traitera de
l'ascension de la nouvelle république
suite à la chute de l'empiré de
l'épisode 6 comme vous le savez via
mandat lauriane il existe de nombreux
restes de l'empiré encore actifs nous
pourrions donc être face à une série un
peu plus tourner dans la politique
et pourquoi pas la mise en lumière de la
famille de peau d'iron qui sont très
liés à l'alliance ou encore la nouvelle
république
nous avons ensuite bien évidemment la
série sur ahsoka tano ahsoka qui revient
en force sur le devant de la scène grâce
à la série de mandats lauriane si la
série sur ahsoka se déroule pendant la
période de mandaloriennes justement on
peut sagement déjà supposer que l'oeuvre
aura un rapport avec l'épisode où est
apparue
protagonistes sans spoiler ahsoka
semblait en recherche de certaines
informations la piste est lancé
néanmoins si on réfléchit logiquement
malgré sans avoir de date
on peut supposer que la série fera son
apparition dans une période où mandat
lauriane serait temps pose entre
guillemets si nous sommes dans la même
période
on pourrait donc s'attendre à 2022 au
minimum puisque mandat lauriane a
officialisé sa troisième saison pour
d'ailleurs il est important à noter que
mandaloriennes se situe environ 25 ans
avant star wars 9
il me semble et dans star wars 9 ray est
la dernière des jedi et la voix d'ahsoka
et présente parmi les autres héros de la
série lors de la scène finale
il est possible que si la série soit en
plusieurs saisons nous ayons la
connaissance de la raison du décès du
personnage mais bon je parle de ça ce
sera dans bien longtemps quand même pour
continuer une série dont nous avons
mentionné l'existence et la raison dans
une récente vidéo
kassian en d'or revient sur le devant de
la scène pour une série centrée sur le
personnage prévue pour 2022 je trouve
l'idée de cette série intéressante par
rapport aux autres productions l'oeuvre
kassian en dehors a clairement pour but
d'étoffer l'univers star wars avec du
nouveau lors montré les prémices de la
rébellion face à l' empire et comme le
dit si bien diego luna dans le trailer
gwan est le film qui connecte les
nouvelles audiences avec les anciens
fans la série kassian d'or permettra de
prolonger cette idée en racontant d'une
nouvelle chose mais lié à l'histoire du
passé nous enchaînons sur l' annonce
d'une série dédiée au personnage de
lando calrissian pour avoir une date
nous sommes sur du fin 2022 voire 2023
très peu d'informations sur le projet on
sait même pas s'il y aura un retour de
donald glover ou bien billy dee williams
mais je vous avoue que je penche plus
pour un donald glover
vous pensez ce que vous voulez de solo
star wars story mais il existe bel et
bien et il est logique disney souhaite
étoffer cette période un jour ou l'autre
notamment avec une série sur l'endos
néanmoins la seule information
concernant la série et qu'il s'agit
d'une série d'événements ce terme
sous-entend très clairement une série à
une seule saison nous monterons
possiblement tous les grands moments de
la vie de landeleau restons curieux pour
le moment ensuite rogue squadron ou
rogue squadron un film prévu pour
l'hiver 2023 il sera le prochain film de
la franchise
aucun indice pour le moment si ce n'est
le titre rogue squadron sont les
meilleurs pilotes de la rébellion
c'est un escadron qui tire son nom de
ceux qui se sont sacrifiés pour
récupérer les plans de l'étoile de la
mort on reste donc dans la lignée de
rogue one
il est très probable qu'on retrouve donc
un potentiel jeune luke ou encore des
personnages iconiques comme big show
wedge par exemple le digne successeur de
clone wars fait également son apparition
on n'allait pas rester longtemps sans
une série d'animations hype comme
l'était clone wars aux rebels the bad
patch se déroule après la guerre des
clones pendant la naissance de l'empiré
galactique the bad patch est une
escouade de super clown on va dire entre
guillemets des clones qui sont
génétiquement un petit peu différent de
leurs semblables et qui les rendent
uniques ils sont déjà parus dans ce
clone wars
donc je pense que beaucoup d'entre vous
ne sont pas forcément surpris de
l'arrivée de la série pour rester dans
les séries d'animation nous avons
également star wars beyond qui possède
un concept plutôt original prévu pour
2021 star wars
wiesel et réalisés par de grands
créateurs japonais est axée sur les jedi
ce sont en gros plusieurs courts
métrages racontant des histoires d'antan
c'est un concept qui risque d'être très
visuel je pense et nous proposer une
manière autre de consommer star wars
une manière beaucoup plus artistique
certainement l'un des projets qui
m'intrigue le plus
star wars
acolyte l'acolyte c'est l'équivalent
d'un apprenti chez les jedi c'est en
gros un aspirant au côté obscur qui n'a
pas encore fait ses preuves et le plus
intéressant dans tout ça est que la
série se déroulerait 200 en avant la
menace fantôme est donc dans les
derniers jours de la haute république
on en parlait récemment avec la question
de la fameuse prochaine trilogie qui
pour beaucoup d'entre vous se
déroulerait pendant la haute république
dit acolytes serait le premier pas
audiovisuel de cette période
et d'ailleurs les sites n'ont pas été
vus depuis des siècles normalement voir
l'émergence du côté obscur et la
jeunesse des heures sombres
bassam beaucoup jeunes et enfin en garde
le plus hype pour la fin star wars droid
story a été annoncé c'est un film
d'animation qui mettra en lumière nos
chers r2d2 et c3po il mérite franchement
c'est des bons c'est des bons non en
vrai ce qui est intéressant avec ce film
est qu'il est annoncé que r2d2 et c3po
guideront un nouveau héros lors de cette
épopée
un nouveau personnage de fait pas de mal
mais surtout r2d2 et c3po sont des
protagonistes secondaires qui ont besoin
d'une présence humaine pour développer
leur histoire tout comme luc anakin ou
ray ce nouveau personnage risque d'être
important et ça m'intrigue beaucoup et
puis bah la fameuse série sur obi-wan
quoi qui se déroulera dix ans après la
revanche des sith et surtout nous aurons
le retour des dden christensen en dark
vador quoi évidemment ewan mcgregor
reprend son rôle et nous serons
spectateur de son exil sur tatouine où
il veillera sur un luc âgé d'environ 10
ans je garde en tête que nous aurons une
potentielle apparition de quoi gones
puisque dans l'épisode 3 yoda souhaité
qu'obi wan fasse quelques exercices un
petit peu particulier comme europe
contacté son ancien maître via la force
si dark vador est présent nous aurons
certainement tout un aspect émotionnel
de la relation détruite
entre obi wan et anakin cela va
clairement faire bizarre de les revoir
ensemble une grosse nostalgie de la
prélogie mais bon le tournage commence à
peine en janvier 2021
donc on a clairement le temps
bon bah voilà comme je vous disais je
pensais vous faire une seule vidéo
réunissant tout le contenu star wars et
marvel mais il ya tellement eu de série
annoncée donc voilà je vous propose
qu'on se retrouve dans une vidéo dédiée
à marvel dès demain matin pour clarifier
tout ça je compte sur vous pour me
partager vos ressentis vos idées vos
opinions concernant toutes ces nouvelles
annonces ou genre si vous avez un membre
de votre famille genre à un oncle de la
belle famille du cousin qui travaille
chez lucasfilm ou disney je compte sur
vous également pour vous abonner à la
chaîne laisser un petit pouce bleu etc
surtout que comme je vous disais vous
êtes beaucoup à regarder sans être
abonné donc profitez-en si vous voulez
ne rater aucun contenu allez que le
léonard soit avec vous c'était argot
rock cha où tout le monde
[Musique]